good morning John and welcome to a
special division of let's understand the
news cuz this morning my government shut
down okay so yesterday in America we had
a government today a little less what
does it mean is the military still
protecting us who's gonna search my bags
at the airport why did it happen how is
even possible who is responsible what is
in my mouth lose the hair was that there
was a hair in my mouth let's go through
it here in America there are two
different rooms full of people who make
the rules in order for something to
become a law they have to agree on it's
also somewhat importantly they approve
the budget which is basically the law
that makes it legal for the government
to spend money the budget is given to
Congress by the President and that it is
treated like any other bill which is to
say very poorly often that abuse of the
budget will take so long that Congress
will have to pass a continuing
resolution because they won't be ready
to put the new budget into effect when
the old budget comes out of effect the
continuing resolution basically just
said let's just do what the old budget
did for a few more weeks while we get
our act together these are generally
very easy to pass because the one very
small step away from doing absolutely
nothing
the problem is that Obamacare which was
passed into law in 2010 and upheld by
the Supreme Court today went into full
swing and the Republicans are not done
fighting it a Republican that House of
Representatives voted on the continuing
resolution with a little thing added
that said Obamacare not gonna happen for
another year the democrat-controlled
Senate is then like no that's not what
the continuing resolution is for it's to
keep the government from shutting down
not making sweeping changes to the most
significant piece of domestic policy in
50 years and the house was like come on
come over and talk to us we got root
beer and the Senate is like no man
holding the government hostage way not
cool and I'm gonna like root beer and in
the house was like see everybody the
Senate won't even talk to us they're
just too cool for school they want the
government to shut down and who doesn't
like root beer interestingly the health
care system is funded separately from
all this stuff so indeed Obamacare went
into effect despite the government
shutdown today I want to learn what
Obamacare is about we just launched a
new channel called healthcare triage and
uploaded a video about that very topic
go watch it now go watch it later
whatever the Republicans don't actually
think that they're gonna stop Obamacare
which is weird right to be have a
problem here if that politicians have
over the years redrawn their district
line so that they are more and more
Republican or more and more Democrat
this way it's easier to win any give
however its radicalized the district so
that if you want to like represent your
ultra Republican or ultra Democrat
district you have to be really
uncooperative in terrible at being
Congress that's sort of the root of the
problem here not an easy problem to fix
as far as what the government shutdown
needs things like museums and national
parks the EPA NASA those things just
close down basically but things like
Defense Transportation Security Border
Patrol food inspectors emergency
readiness those people are accepted and
they get to go to work today Postal
Service is self-funded so that's fine
Social Security and Medicare and
Medicaid are all separate from this so
they continue operating starting today
about 800,000 people are out of the job
including a very good friend of mine so
I'm kind of mad about that until
Congress gets attacked together no one
knows how quickly this will be resolved
it could be three days it could be three
weeks but it will be resolved because I
have confidence that Congress wants the
country to exist people will lose pay
and we probably will lose some great
employees to the private sector and the
whole world will laugh at our inability
to complete even the most mundane tasks
it's embarrassing and stupid and to be
frank at the dangerous game we're
playing but we will get through it John
I'll see you on Friday